[Musique]
que pensez vous des jeunes filles c'est
évidemment un des garçons que nous avons
posé cette question exactement à huit
garçons choisi dans des milieux
différents
ces huit jeunes gens nous vous les
présentons tout d'abord dans leur milieu
michel levieux de la borne 25 ans
technicien dans les plastiques alors
parler serait un excellent meneur
syndical jean ouvrier tourneur 18 ans
habite la banlieue un vélomoteur et une
grande maturité d'esprit pour son âge
gérard étudiants dessinateur
publicitaire 18 ans c'est un artiste qui
a vécu sont à terre il adore la musique
ses parents habitent la province pierre
employés de bureau habite dieppe 20 ans
et 6 mois est venu nous voir juste avant
son départ pour arras où il est
mobilisent
philippe étudiants 19 ans vit seule à
paris
ses parents sont en normandie
il adore le cheval suit la mode de près
et passionné pour le naturel
gérard élèves en mathématiques
élémentaires à 19 ans ses camarades
l'ont baptisé orphée car il chante sans
arrêt alain danseurs élève au
conservatoire 17 ans danse dans les
vallées de cluny avec ses gains paye ses
cours c'est un vrai gars broche
jean-pierre étudiants en archéologie à
l'école du louvre 20 ans vit dans un
autre monde
un surnom qui ont dit non ramsès c'est
un descendant des pros chevalier
ne trouvez-vous pas que les jeunes
filles manquent de plus dorée pour trop
souvent des avances aux garçons il y en
avait pas tout il faut pas tout mettre
tout le monde dans le même dans le même
sac les certaines filles jalouses les
blousons noirs les jupons noir pardon
et puis vous avez les filles bien vous
avez le milieu également un alors il
faut pas dire parce qu'une jeune fille
on tombe sur une jeune fille qui fait
une avance aux garçons et bob toutes les
jeunes filles ne font pas les avances
aux garçons heureusement du reste je
trouve que les jeunes filles ne manque
pas de pudeur non puisqu'elles sont
encore jeunes filles mais quel point ça
qu'elles font des avances aux garçons
elle s'arrange d'une manière très
différente et sont assez coquette à ses
malicieux pour nous de comprendre et je
pense que la généralité est à peu près
englober quand vous sortez tous les ou
normal qu'une jeune fille est simple non
je trouve pas ça normal ça reste de
chevalerie la galanterie française
réputée
oui je trouve normal que nos jeunes
filles paye sa part mais il y a deux
catégories de jeunes filles il y à la
jeune fille avec qui vous sortez mais
que vous connaissez à peine et il y à la
jeune fille qui est une camarade avec
qui vous sortez souvent alors sept
camarades est au courant de vos besoins
financiers et c'est que vous ne pouvez
pas toujours payés justement sa place de
cinéma et d'elle-même et demandera à la
payer avec une jeune fille avec laquelle
vous sortez par exemple pour la première
fois il est normal que vous payez mais
il y a beaucoup de jeunes filles
maintenant justement qui refuse qu'un
garçon leur payent leur place parce
qu'elles ne veulent pas être tributaire
de ce garçon elles veulent rester libres
de leurs gestes
croyez vous à la camaraderie à une
camaraderie durable entre filles et
garçons d'une camarade ordre filles et
garçons j'y crois mais durable je ne
peux pas me prononcer oui je crois la
camaraderie durable entre jeunes filles
et garçons car j'ai eu déjà le fait en
moi même même
je crois même plus que camarades on peut
être amis je trouve que on peut débuter
par le flirt et ensuite devenir de très
bons camarades avec les filles et ses
camarades les épouses auriez-vous eh
bien oui oui je poserai ses camarades si
réellement nous nous aimions fin d'un
amour durable évidemment comment pouvez
vous savoir qui sera durable
alors cela mais bien sûr j'ai poserait
une de mes camarades c'est bien souvent
dans les camarades contre quand on voit
la femme la plus parfaite quoi enfin
s'il n'ya jamais une femme parfaite ça
je m'entends à votre avis la femme
mariée doit-elle rester chez elles ou
travailler à l'extérieur chez eux plus
tôt
je pense parce que ça prépare une vie
plus calme de la femme d'intérieur
la mère de famille et c'est plus le
métier d'une femme plutôt que de
travailler à l'extérieur ce qui revient
à être le travail du mari car vous
convenez que de tenir son intérieur et
élever ses enfants c'est un travail s'il
fait un travail un gros travail est
essentiellement féminin après six mois
je préférerais que la femme mariée reste
chez elle il ya déjà beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail à faire dans une
maison à s'occuper du ménage des enfants
la popote enfin tout la lessive si si
c'est un boulot immense mais vous savez
à l'époque actuelle
un salaire c'est vraiment très dur pour
vivre à à plusieurs sur un salaire même
à deux c'est très difficile alors mon
opinion d'accord la femme mariée à la
maison mais quelle quand même quelque
chose à la fin du mois que pensez-vous
de l'indépendance féminine au sein du
mariage comme les vacances seuls les
sorties seul non seulement contre on est
unis c'est pour la vie on va ensemble
partout a alors là je suis tout à fait
contre dans la mesure du possible ou le
mari justement peut suivre sa femme
les jeunes filles trouvent que vous
n'êtes plus romantiques pourquoi
c'est le les temps modernes qui veulent
ça je pense la société a chassé le
romantisme
vous ne regrettez pas un peu aussi quand
même alors pourquoi les loups pain je
n'ai pas dit je ne veux pas tout d'abord
c'est parce que je pratique quand même
la danse classique et la danse classique
c'est quelque chose de romantique dans
ses traits de très agréable quoi et je
crois quand même qu'il ya quand même
certaines jeunes filles romantiques mais
vu notre taille et notre époque
elle ne veut pas voir les romantiques
elles veulent danser le rock le bob et
le twist et tout ce qui suit tout ce qui
suit aimez vous les jeunes filles
maquillées
non je rohr de ça surtout à notre époque
s'en aperçoit beaucoup car les fonds de
teint ont fait une grande fureur et cela
cache le naturel la beauté de la femme
ça madame je n'aime pas moi c'est un pot
de peinture
il est la qualité essentielle pour une
femme a pris à mon avis c'est là la
simplicité mais j'ajoute aussi la
féminité naturellement je crois qu'il ya
deux qualités essentielles pour une
femme tout d'abord la féminité puisque
c'est une femme est ensuite la fidélité
aussi la féminité la qualité essentielle
pour une femme c'est la féminité mais
qu'elle ne soit pas trop aidé en cela
grâce élégance le charme sa beauté en
même temps quoique une femme n'est pas
forcément il n'est pas forcé qu'une
femme soit belle quoi pour que l puisse
vous charmer assez agréablement le
charme la féminité la fidélité la
gentillesse la grâce du format ces trois
qualités bien si du tonnerre quel est
votre idéal féminin un idéal féminin of
soul et j'en avais eu ce serait à lui
jamais un idéal on ne va jamais on pense
son idéal une femme blonde à une brune
bien mon idéal c'est quand même la
petite fille que j'étais dans mon coeur
est pour l'instant je n'ai pas du tout
d'idéal parce que je vais voir tel film
aussitôt l'actrice la vedette me plaît
je veux voir un autre film
la vedette me plaît aussi et pourtant
elle est tout à fait différente de la
première
alors je n'ai pas d'idéal et je pense
qu'il viendra un jour l'oriental type
oriental
je pensais marina vlady alors là je n'ai
absolument pas d'idée préconçue pas une
vedette pas une actrice rien non non non
je me suis jamais posé la question je
dois dire que je n'ai je n'y ai jamais
pensé mais je crois que ça viendra assez
normalement oui ça sera normal et puis
les choses se font en comme elles
doivent se faire mais je m'inquiète pas
pour ça alors pour conclure que pensez
vous des jeunes filles elles sont
perfides
il faut s'en méfier sont très bonne
comédienne
ce sont des ingénieux père vient perfide
elles sont susceptibles et elles veulent
toujours avoir raison
elles sont capricieuses et manque
quelquefois de sincérité
ce sont deux chipies à facettes
[Musique]